perhaps no single artist has had a
greater impact on how we imagine alien
life than wayne barlow widely considered
the father of modern speculative biology
barlow has worked for decades as a
creature designer for everything from
avatar to pacific rim yet perhaps
barlow's most monumental alien world
comes from his legendary book expedition
which depicts an extraterrestrial
ecosystem with so much originality and
detail that reading it truly feels like
getting lost on another planet the book
was even made into a tv special for the
discovery channel called alien planet
which was honestly one of my favorite
things to watch as a kid the world at
the center of the book and documentary
called darwin 4 is one i've wanted to
document myself for a long time so for
this entry into the archive we'll take a
deep dive into the biology and
ecosystems of barlow's one-of-a-kind
planet in honor of the book's logbook
style storytelling this entry will be
told as the first hand account of an
expedition across darwin for his surface
and if you find the planet as incredible
as i do i've got links below where you
can purchase barlow's book and support
his work now let's begin our expedition
my story begins with this single blurry
photo taken by a faster than light probe
exploring the far reaches of the galaxy
the image shows alien life is present in
the fourth planet of the distant
darwinian system but what kind of life
form is this alien how large is it and
what other lifeforms might it co-exist
with there's only one way to find out
after a journey of many light years i
arrive at darwin iv from orbit my first
scans indicate the planet is a dry hot
house world the only visible body of
water is a peculiar purple ocean of
unknown properties scans also indicate
darwin 4 possesses an oxygen-rich
atmosphere and less than 2 3 earth
gravity meaning life on darwin 4 may
well be gigantic i'll have to proceed
carefully
touching down in the northern hemisphere
i find a sweeping grassland dominated by
titanic plant structures called gourd
trees nearly 15 stories high these trees
stand on a matrix of root-like stilts if
these are the plants of this world the
animals might be true titans
not far from the grove something is
squatting low to the ground consulting
the field guide of an explorer who came
before me i identify this creature as an
arrow tongue while it doesn't appear to
have eyes a series of low clicks tells
me it can see with an organic sonar
system and likely knows i'm here
rearing up to its full height the
aerotongue reveals it's a t-rex sized
apex predator unlike all top earth
predators however the aerotongue doesn't
possess jaws instead it feeds with a
straw-like appendage on its mouth which
is common among all liquivores a group
of tube mouth predators that includes
the arrow tongue and this arrow tongue
seems hungry
but not for me the preferred food of an
arrow tongue are the gyro sprinters
herbivores with highly unusual body
plans while they spend much of their
time resting they're the fastest of all
land animals on darwin 4 yet the gyro
sprinter's ability to careen across the
grassland at incredible speeds is a
tricky thing considering they only have
two legs to keep balance they possess a
set of hyper-developed hull tiers
club-shaped organs which earth animals
like crane flies use to keep their
bodies stabilized during motion a key
trait for the gyro sprinter which must
always be ready to flee speaking of
which i think it's best i leave these
two to the chase
not far from this unfolding drama i spot
a leathery rayback trotting across the
grassland a smaller relative of the
colossal aerotongue the quick solitary
raybacks are in many ways the cheetahs
of this alien savannah yet the rayback's
most notable features their exaggerated
dorsal spires are something of a
biological enigma if we look at earth
animals for clues as to the function of
these spines we find some chameleons
possess similar bony ridges to appear
larger from the side and to intimidate
rivals it's a curious strategy but if it
works for the chameleon it's certainly
possible it would work on darwin 4 for
the rayback
traveling northwards i'm lucky enough to
glimpse a mighty hunter standing
triumphant over its latest quarry this
ambush predator is called a prairie ram
and true to its name this particular
liquivore hunts by ramming its prey with
its pointed skull while no earth
predators hunt in quite the same way
some species have evolved to ram into
each other in territorial displays in
particular bighorn sheep have evolved
skulls and horns that can absorb
tremendous concussive force thanks to
their internal structure we can theorize
that the interior of the prairie ram
skull likely has a similar makeup
at the edge of the grasslands i watch a
duo of mid-sized herbivores called
prismalopes craze in the shade of a
curious tree but it's not the
prismalopes i'm focused on upon closer
inspection the apparent tree behind them
doesn't seem to be a plant at all this
is a butcher tree a life form with a
deadly secret it scent lures in
herbivores and when one gets close the
butcher tree spears it with its branch
daggers
scans confirm this life form is closer
to animal than plant i better keep my
distance
knight is now falling on darwin four and
in the darkness the prong heads stalk
the savannah
these well-muscled pack hunters are the
wolves of darwin 4 and move with
surprising speed
cresting a hill i see what they're
hunting the gyro sprinter from earlier
survived the chase with the aerotongue
but is now in even more danger racing
across the plains the gyro sprinter is
incredibly fast but the prong heads have
the numbers advantage unlike the
arrowtongue they can coordinate in a
pack to cut off their prey but this
gyrosprinter is a survivor and manages
to give them the slip on darwin 4 it
pays to be the quickest
with the morning now just a few hours
away i've made a significant discovery i
followed alone way back beyond the
savannah to the edge of a mysterious
forest this new environment might be
home to all manner of distinct life
forms but the only way to know for sure
is to venture deeper
i don't have to go far on the periphery
of the forest a huge creature shakes the
ground so tall that it towers over the
trees this is a grove back one of the
largest species native to darwin iv
strange tree-like structures grow from
its back which might help the grove back
remain camouflaged while it slumbers
given the grove back size however it
seems unlikely this creature would fear
any predator instead as the sun rises i
wonder if perhaps the grove back has a
symbiotic relationship with the plants
on its back gaining energy from their
photosynthesis much like an earth leaf
sheep a rare type of sea slug that
almost looks like a miniature grove back
from certain angles in any case the
grove backs are truly awe-inspiring i'll
have to make sure they don't step on me
though
deeper into the forest i spot a curious
lifeform reclining on a branch far above
me this is a dagger wrist an agile
arboreal predator that rules the upper
treetops thanks to its deadly bladed
pribiscus which is the closest thing to
a functioning jaw on darwin iv
in a burst of speed the daggerus leaps
to another tree scaling the side of the
trunk by using the claw-like arms that
are its namesake almost like climbing
spikes and in the canopy the dagger
wrist rejoins a troop of its own kind
this family unit is composed of a young
infant and two parents and their pack
behavior showcases a new side to darwin
life social interaction
while dagurists might be deadly
predators like earth monkeys it seems
they are sociable living in troops of
one or more families and looking out for
each other after reuniting with its
troop the daggerist goes on the hunt
once more and i get to witness it
leaping from a tree and gliding to the
ground using sails under its arm soaring
in a manner quite similar to many
species of gliding earth animals the
hunt doesn't last long the daggerist is
a brutal hunter and an animal i should
be wary of
on the other edge of the forest i see a
lone grove back that seems to be under
attack the air is filled with a swarm of
needle-like predators which are
launching themselves at the titanic
grove back from all directions these are
beach quills and while it seems
impossible for these tiny lifeforms to
take down such a behemoth the grove back
is clearly affected by their onslaught i
realize the insect-like beach quills
must be highly toxic it might seem
strange that tiny organisms like beach
quills could be so venomous but animals
like the small blue spotted ribbon tail
rey are some of the most venomous life
forms in the oceans despite their
relatively insignificant size
so it makes sense that a colony of beach
quills working in tandem would be able
to take down all number of unprepared
organisms that wander into their domain
for beach quill territory marks the edge
of a new biome one home to far greater
dangers than the forest
two days into my expedition i've reached
a sea of shifting purple liquid the
properties of which are highly
mysterious this landscape appears to be
the same ocean i saw from space which
now doesn't seem like an ocean at all
with caution i take a sample of this
strange mass
looking under a field microscope i find
this ocean isn't made of water molecules
but living cells the entire ocean is
actually a single massive life form in
amoebic sea that blankets five percent
of the surface of planet darwin iv
looking towards the horizon i can see
this vast colony stretches far into the
distance and is a biome in and of itself
a question grows in my mind what
life-forms have evolved to live upon
this sentient ocean
a low roar thunders across the sea the
mightiest creatures i will ever witness
are approaching at last they come into
full view
these are emperor sea striders the
largest life forms i've discovered on my
voyage towering over the amoebic sea
like living mountains without a doubt
these are the creatures the probe first
glimpse that started the entire
expedition but seeing them in person is
an entirely different experience in
order to sustain such an awe-inspiring
size the sea strider's biology is one of
a kind particularly their feeding system
the sea striders possess two mouth-like
openings located on their feet allowing
them to feed on the limitless amoebic
sea while they stride across it it's the
perfect food source for such a vast life
form and though a storm rages around
them the emperors see striders march on
undaunted
in just a short time i've seen more
wonders than i can count on the surface
of darwin iv yet i suspect the mysteries
of this planet are just beginning i'll
venture farther across darwin 4 in part
2 of this expedition investigating the
more extreme and often more dangerous
life of the skies in polar regions and
if you have a particular creature you
want me to be sure to cover put it in
the comments if you find the life of
darwin 4 as fascinating as i do i'd
encourage you to purchase the book and
check out more of wayne barlow's
incredible work once again links are in
the description and as always thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this entry
please lend your support to help make
videos like these possible by liking
subscribing and hitting the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things
curious see you in the next video
you